[Music]
cardi b is giving us a rare glimpse of
her son
the mom of two posted a sweet birthday
tribute to her hubby offset on tuesday
praising him for the man that he's
becoming and the father that he already
is what is offset like as a dad he
already has three kids so i already fell
in love uh the way that he was a dad
already i'm like oh my god i can have a
little one with this guy he's really
good he's really good along with the
caption cardi shared a number of photos
and videos with offset
[Music]
plus a handful of sweet moments between
the rapper and his kids including this
precious video of the clout rapper
cradling their newborn son in the
hospital look closely and you can almost
see an eye and tiny nose i love
everything about motherhood i like i
like everything this is one of the first
times the mama bear has given us a
glimpse of her second child who was born
in september not to mention the couple
still hasn't shared their son's name and
it's like oh snappity snap snap but
cardi was equally as protective of their
first born three-year-old culture here's
what she told et several months after
welcoming the couple's daughter i'm
scared to share her to the world you
know i'm scared there's so many mean
people out there
but sometimes i just want to show people
how beautiful and how
precious she is she's so precious
seriously it's just there's a lot of
people that just have crazy minds you
know
want to protect that she's my little
ducky and when cardi spoke with e.t the
following year it was pretty clear she
loves being a mama what does it mean to
be a mother
it means everything it's it's like a
feeling that it's indescribable
it's
like like
love joy it's a switch
you know what i'm saying it's like an
automatic smile right it's automatic
worries
sad you know what i'm saying it's
everything and i think i mean i mean
everything to her like is that when i
she sees me she kicks her feet so fast
it's like she loves me meanwhile the wap
singer recently revealed her son's
latest milestone that left her beaming
quote my son holding his bottle with
both hands already cardi continued
writing i'm trying to remember if kk was
doing that around 3 months old or if
this is one of the superpowers these
pandemic babies coming with
so if one brings you this much joy
would you double the joy
i i want to have more kids you do yeah
the mom of two has told us a number of
times that she wants more kids so
there's a chance her and offset's latest
addition might not be their last
you know
how whatever my body could take and i
feel like i can take
you know everybody so it's easy to be
like oh i want five four kids but it's
like can you really take that
you know it's it as i feel like the more
my baby grows i see like the different
levels
and this is gonna be different levels
all the time
you